we know you miss a famous theme song but
you might also be wondering who is maki
and what does she want with master chief
how excited were you when you saw the
warthog appear and what's up with all
those tentacles this is halo find the
halo win the war halo fans across the
world were probably excited to get a
sneak peek at some of the weapons that
would appear in the upcoming halo tv
series one of the most exciting to debut
in the trailer is the beloved energy
sword the plasma weapon is a favorite of
close combat players with the ability to
take out an adversary in one blow more
often than not some halo players will
find a great hiding spot and take out an
opposing player with one swift stroke of
the energy sword we would have been
shocked if the halo series didn't
feature the glowing weapon
and does it make several appearances in
the trailer we're sure it'll be used
heavily throughout the series also in
the lengthy trailer we see some of the
more commonly used weapons in halo like
the plasma pistol assault rifle battle
rifle sniper rifle the turret and more
there are three different types of
turrets in the halo games but in the
trailer we see a detachable one from a
stand that master chief snatches we're
sure to see more weapons when the series
debuts but it's good to know the folks
at paramount plus are sticking with the
classics
face it if there's one thing you
remember from the original halo combat
evolved whether you only played it once
or spent hours blowing up your friends
in blood gulch it's the m12 force
application vehicle of course that's not
the name you probably use more commonly
known as the warthog these massive
open-air all-wheel drive vehicles were
everything you ever hoped your jeep
would be capable of zooming across any
landscape with the perfect rumble and
the greatest of ease frankly there's no
understating just how important the
warthog was when it came to the original
game's development and success as game
designer jamie griezmann told gamesradar
it was just so cool to watch a squad of
jeeps driving across the terrain that we
wanted to drive them ourselves in some
ways halo is the story of the warthog
and the universe we built to drive it
around in bringing the world of halo to
live action was always going to also
require bringing the warthog to life but
it's hard to imagine that there's a
single fan out there who didn't feel an
excited tingle go down their spine and
this iconic video game vehicle finally
drove across the screen while the
warthog was previously confirmed by set
photos the vehicle's presence in the
trailer is a sign that the halo
franchise has finally completed its long
drive to the live-action world
as we near the end of the trailer
audiences get a glimpse of maki a new
addition to the halo world played by
peaky blind as actor charlie murphy
marky is an imposing figure she also
seems to be on the side of the bad guys
or at least an opponent of humanity
humans
surrender to the covenant
she might seem like a human herself but
one thing is clear she's definitely no
ally markey will be working on behalf of
the covenant the alien race master chief
and the rest of his spartan crew are
fighting in halo season 1. what makes
this particular character so intriguing
is that she's completely original to the
show with no analogues existing in any
of the previously released halo video
games news of murphy's cast scene was
originally announced by variety in
november 2019. the report revealed marky
is quote an orphaned human who was
raised by the alien covenant and shares
a contempt for humanity what the
contempt is rooted in will hopefully be
revealed in season 1 and help audiences
understand what makes this new character
tick
in the quickest of glimpses you can see
marquis standing in a dramatic black
outfit with what appears to be the
anodyne spirit behind her also known as
a forerunner ship this impressive
geometric warship is a power source for
high charity the holy city of the
covenant within the mobile planetoid
station of high charity lies a large
capital city with the anodyne spirit a
four runner keyship that looks something
like an otherworldly eiffel tower
sitting at the center of it so it seems
safe to say that we'll be traveling to
the sacred covenant station of high
charity at some point in the series the
blink and you music clip is generating
quite a bit of controversy online some
twitter users are taking issue with the
possibility that a main antagonist from
the covenant could be a human and that
she might have some level of power
within the leadership on high charity
for now we don't know the extent of her
authority and if she resides on high
charity or is just passing through on
the orders of a higher up
there is quite a terrifying monster
toward the end of the trailer which
appears to be entirely made of tentacles
at least that's all we can see this
tentacled monster doesn't appear to have
any interest to newcomer maki which
makes us think that this is not the
gravemind if it was as a part of the
flood it wouldn't be allied with the
covenant so what is it we'll need more
clarity on this when the show finally
debuts another tender called being from
the halo universe this could be is a
horror
granted in the halo world horror gargs
are super computers and in the trailer
the tentacles look to be very organic
and not very tech like paragraphs
however do serve the covenant so it
would make sense why marquee is safe
from them in this scene we also have to
keep the possibility open that this
monsterish being is something new
entirely and not something from the
video game's law there's also the
possibility that the tentacles aren't
their own organism but parts of marky's
body or under her control in some way
we'll no doubt be learning more about
the show as more footage comes out but
in the meantime we'll be sitting here
charging our plasma rifles in
anticipation for the show's premiere on
march 24th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite video games are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]